مرحبًا ، ما الذي تفعلونه هنا
في انتظاركم
[موسيقى] ،
شكرًا ،
كيف حالك ، هل يمكن
أن أرتدي المزيد من الملابس
[تصفيق]
كيف فعلت ذلك ما هو
أكبر حيوان أليف في مونيكا
يرتدي زي البشر وهذا صحيح
كتبت راشيل روس أ  رسالة
وطالبته بقراءتها قبل أن يعودوا معًا
كم عدد الصفحات التي كان فيها هذا الحرف 18 صفحة ،
نعم 18 صفحة أمامية
وخلفية أمامية وخلفية صحيحة
يا إلهي ،
لا أصدق أنك لم تقل لي
هذه الشخصية بحاجة إلى الضحك لأنني
لن أكون قادرًا على المرور
بمشهد واحد مع هذا الرجل
وقد نظرت إليه للتو وذهبت
وكان هذا
هو الذي ركض فيه ونظر إلى علامته لا ، لقد
تعثرت في
ليزا ، هل خطرت ببالك عنك
تعرف  حسنًا ، ربما يمكننا عمل حلقة أخرى ،
ربما يمكننا عمل
فيلم هو أن شيئًا ما كنت
تفكر فيه حتى
لا ، لا ، أنا آسف لأنني
لم أحفر الحفرة الضخمة ثم يتذكر جوي
شيئًا رأيته في هذا الشيء  اكتشاف
قناة
لك